it's an honor to have uh Kevin o lry aka
Mr Wonderful appear before the small
business committee today chairman
Williams ranking member of Basquez and
members of the committee thank you for
giving me time to testify about the
state of small business in America I'm
the chairman of oares an ETF indexing
firm and chairman of O Ventures
management a private equity and Venture
investment firm as an investor I support
entrepreneurs at every stage of their
Journeys I have dozens of family run
businesses in our investment portfolios
my by definition of a small business is
a private firm often family-owned that
employs between five and 500 people
these are hardworking men and women that
basically account for 60% of job
creation in America there is no denying
they are the backbone of the economy for
decades the US economy has enjoyed
historically low interest rates access
to Capital at low cost is always the key
for funding receivables Capital
expenditures and making payroll for
small businesses in America the majority
of these Services were provided by the
network of over 4,000 Regional Banks
almost a year ago the network began to
falter Silicon Valley Bank and Signature
Bank failed and first rep public Bank
was bailed out by taxpayers and then
sold off to JP Morgan this occurred
while the Federal Reserve was raising
rates at an unprecedented Pace from
almost zero to the current 5.5% terminal
rate Regional Banks immediately faced
heighten scrutiny of their balance
sheets and liquidity ratios and now Bank
policies are underview by their
Regulators the predictable reaction was
for the banks to tighten their loan
books this was immediately felt by
hundreds of thousands of small business
owners in every sector and geography in
America not only did their rates
increase but Regional Bank liquidity
dried up too in many cases now they have
to make use of the private Shadow
banking Network at rates of 16 to 22% at
the same time Federal programs like the
PPP had ended and the employee retention
credit payments were suspended by the
IRS in Q4 of 23 to date they' have not
resumed and the whole ERC program is
currently scheduled to end on April 15
2025 or even sooner unfortunately the
majority of small business owners have
no idea if they qualify for any of the
programs inside of the inflation
reduction act the chips act and science
act obviously and infrastructure act
small businesses do not have the
resources to retain lobbyists legal and
financial advisors that interpret the
acts and manage the application process
if small businesses in America are
responsible for 60% of domestic jobs why
aren't these acts written to spend 60
cents of every dollar on them especially
when their traditional sources of
funding in government support programs
have ended or been suspended instead it
looks to the market like the IRA chips
and infrastructure Acts were written
specifically for the S&P 500 companies
that have no trouble accessing Capital
yet only create 40% % of jobs in America
many of these in foreign
subsidiaries I would like to suggest
some recommendations to the committee
number one create a payroll Protection
Program to protect non-interest bearing
payroll accounts in Regional and
Community Banks during the inevitable
consolidations of over 4,000 regionals
down to a market stable number I first
heard this idea from sen Senator haggy
and I think it would be helpful number
two work with the numerous agencies that
are implementing both the IRA chips and
infrastructure acts to ensure small
businesses receive their fair share of
these programs form a bipartisan Council
that advocates for small business in
America that is always at the table when
new policy is being considered this
would ensure that new government
programs and laws are actually
supporting small businesses and job
creation in America thank you very much